أعتقد أن الإجراء الذي
نأمل أن نراه كمجتمع كما
رأيناه في الأشهر القليلة الماضية هو تعويضات
نريد إجراء محادثات جادة حقيقية
حول التعويضات حول تحمل المؤسسة
للمساءلة الحقيقية عن ذلك
فقط.  لقد كان للتو نوعًا من
البيانات الشخصية عن الأسف والأسى
لتأثيرات تجارة الذبح ولكني
أعتقد أنه من المهم جدًا أن نفهم
كيف انعكس ذلك عبر
المجتمعات في إفريقيا ومنطقة البحر
الكاريبي وكيف أنه لا يزال يؤثر على الناس في
المملكة المتحدة اليوم الذين لا يزالون  العيش في وسط
تلك التفاوتات كنوع
من آخر بقايا الإمبراطورية ،
أعتقد أنه من المهم حقًا
تسليط الضوء على ذلك ، لذا أعتقد أن المضي
قدمًا كورقة بحثية وكمجتمع
سنقوم بتوجيه تلك
المحادثات الصعبة للغاية  وكان هذا
التعاون مع الملك الآن
فرصة لإنشاء نقطة انطلاق تلك
أكثر من 400 جامايكي سعيد
جاؤوا للبحث عن عمل في بريطانيا
ومستعدون وراغبون في القيام به  أي نوع من
الوظائف التي من شأنها أن تساعد الوطن الأم على
طول طريق الازدهار